Carly  Perry Carroll is that her first Carol  Carol yeah she's here  validation works two ways for not only  the client but for me as a media so that  I know that I'm on the right path of  them and interpreting the messages  clearly and accurately does she have a  dog that she really loves or is that  your dog well it's like a boxer he's  you're not does she love your dog no I  don't know if your dog ever barks or  stares at things that aren't there  literally dogs are very sensitive to  spiritually that's your mom that was  weird  she loved Oliver so that was really  weird how it was coming through and  Oliver he sits and stares at the wall  and I'm always like freaked out when he  does it so it's nice to know that you  know she's still around